walker
the first baseman tonight
dribbler up the middle backhanded by
mcmahon they get one and the throw gets
away from murphy here comes varsho and
the diamondbacks have a run
did they even get martay at second base
he's standing in there at third
he was signalling into the third base
dugout as he was running from second to
third over the mound that's mcmahon who
flips onto story
type play there he kind of dragged his
right foot across the bag
boy that is close
so varsho comes in martay is out
and walker is safe at first it's one
nothing diamondbacks
josh fuentes the cousin of nolan arenado
arenado
is done for the gear with a shoulder
problem
this is well hit left field one more
chance for david
it's off the wall he tried a little deep
there gets it back in quickly and
fuentes has a two out double this is a
missile fastball down and into fuentes
the way he tossed his bat away i think
he thought he might have gotten enough
of that one but
david does a nice job of going back to
the wall realizing he didn't have a
chance to get to the wall to make the
play
and the carom comes right to him but
fuentes slides in with a two-out double
with two outs fuentes at second murphy's
coming up he had a ball of deep rights
two and two on murphy
and murphy lines up base hit covering
around third is fuentes to tie up the
ball game so daniel murphy with a sharp
single to even this thing up that looked
like the murphy who throughout his
career has been one of the toughest outs
at baseball two out magic yeah that was
great to see double and then the murphy
single on a 2-2 pitch and here's diaz
who doubled his first time up argument
for every single guy we just talked
about and we really did
diaz lines this one to deep left god
just snuck over the wall
elias diaz puts the rockies up 3-1
i don't think that thing got more 12
feet off the ground the whole way
second home run for diaz
luke weaver has given up 10 home runs on
the season he had given up only two in
the last seven outings
just the third one to a right-handed
batter
garrett hampson leads off to colorado
fifth against luke weaver
john jay out there in center he won't
get to this one it's off the 413 mark
hampson can really run he's thinking
three he'll put the brakes on at second
and settle for a lead-off double
and ramel tapia coming up an rbi
opportunity for rhymeout hanson leads
off second and this ball is hit to the
left side there's another one in the
opposite field rounding third coming
home is hampton 4-1 colorado get the
ball and play good things will happen he
had a big baltimore chopper over eduardo
escobar
and tapia has his 17th rbi
charlie lifts this ball to left tapia
can run here's perrault to get behind
the baseball the former cardinal pitcher
is going to have it cut off and that is
uh
very good execution two productive outs
brings tapio along and the rockies have
a five to one lead
two on all of a sudden one out john jay
coming up jay
hit a ground ball to first back in the
third
and this is going to get through a base
hit
payment smith around third he's coming
home pilar's throw in todd what a throw
by pilar
[Applause]
who's up five to two as they bat in the
sixth
2-0 on diaz
and that's going to be a third hit for
elias spilly you know all he needs
one of those corey sullivan triples
he could do it he's got enough wheels he
actually does
he does i when was the last time we saw
a catcher have a cycle was it uh benji
benji molina with the giants
one and two on mcmahon
and this ball is hit pretty well left
center field
and really well god that's it well
it sounded loud and with mcmahon
you never know he's so darn strong
he goes opposite field two-run homer and
now the rockies lead it's 7-2
the rockies have committed four errors
we've had pass balls wild pitches
that'll roll into left center get walker
home to make it 7-3 rbi for eduardo
who's now hit safely in five straight
three two on charlie oh this ball is
lined to right for a base hit tapia will
come down and the rockies have an eighth
run it is a two ribby night for blackman
this ball to center fielded deep and
plain chases john jay
charlie long striding it around third he
gets a green light takes a look trevor
on his way to third triple rbi t
story this is a roller that's going to
get a run home
so josh will get an rpi out of that as
story scores
and this is a bouncer to trevor
and that's the ball game the rockies win
it 10-3 tonight